grizzlies forcing a turnover morant has  allen on a wing  josh to the rim lays it up and in and  the chrisleys have the lead  lead him young fella so this team needs  they need a leader to be a leader  number 12 is showing up with numbers lob  friends oh baby  time out portland  oh my man petey we supposed to be in the  building  he's going to be jumping up and down  right now portland with six turnovers in  the first half  five here in the quarter grizzlies a  dozen points in the third  of a portland turnovers and it's all  getting done  with grizzlies defense  [Music]  and that man right there the defense  leading to offense but what has happened  the pace of the game has changed  must be nice to get up like this  even when i dream partner i don't dream  jumping that high no  nine points for